an homage to george floyd here in paris
across france other rallies are also
being held now the pressure from
demonstrations like this
over the last week or so has forced the
french government to take action
the country's interior minister vowed
zero
tolerance when you wear the uniform the
blue uniform of the law
you are never above it on the contrary
we owe it to ourselves even more than
others to be exemplary
so i want zero tolerance for racism in
law enforcement
that statement came in the wake of a new
racism scandal
a facebook group used by police members
was outed for
repeatedly using racist and sexist terms
while also
mocking victims of police brutality
in another closed group on whatsapp
police are accused of insulting a fellow
officer
who is black with racist language
christophe casanas seized the moment
calling for an inquiry he also announced
the end of the controversial chokehold
technique
used to detain suspects but is it enough
i think those people should be fired we
need to identify those behind
those racist messages and fire them i
think it is
unacceptable that the police who should
be protecting us don't follow the laws
themselves
they should face the consequences i have
witnessed
police brutality for my son
who was coming back my son is a mixed
blood
was coming from abroad he was caught
at a railway station and he was
you know migrated because because he
said
he's black we don't necessarily have
confidence in the government because
this problem has been around for years
we get the feeling that kastner's
actions are a bit opportunistic
because it is only what happened in the
us that finally made them do something
to increase their credibility
but we don't know if in the end things
will change
that the policeman will be better
trained or if the situation with
discrimination and racism will finally
be taken seriously
i'm not certain that something will
change i think that the measures taken
by the government
are more aimed at calming down the
people than really solving the problem
of racism
and put real policies in place and
police unions have criticized the
changes
there are political announcements and
then there is the reality on the ground
the impression given is that everyone is
nice except the police who are mean
we used the stranglehold when we're
faced with an individual who is
resisting arrest
so what will we do instead well the
tribute here
is to george floyd france is also
remembering its own who've died in what
families claim are questionable
circumstances
and there is anger over accusations of
police brutality
figures just released by francis police
watchdog show almost 1
500 complaints were made in 2019 against
officers
an increase of almost 25 percent
more than half of those complaints were
for alleged violence
up by 41 compared to 2018.
the interior minister says 30 judicial
investigations
have been launched of those 22 were
brought to justice
the fight against racism and issues over
police brutality
is not new when macron ran his
presidential campaign in 2017
he promised to be uncompromising i want
to change the culture
the management and the recruitment of
french police when there is manifestly a
problem
the police hierarchy must be challenged
but three years on
the same questions are still being asked
afresh
promises are still being made what
people here
at this and other protests want is
action
and not more words charlotte evinsky
rt paris a former police commissioner
maurice siniole told us that the problem
of racism goes far beyond just police
brutality
today's police officers face a great
challenge they have to assert their
authority
and only to demonstrate is no longer
enough so
all of this violence that we can condemn
is a consequence of social violence not
police violence
i think that's where we're wrong the
police system in america has nothing to
do with the national police
which depends on the state the police in
the united states
is a myriad of different police
structures mostly municipal
they have different recruitment
standards different levels of trading
everything
and you can't compare france and the
united states here
after all the purpose for france is not
to live in unity but to find a common
destiny
you